this is a one-man operation I do the
whole thing myself
this watch Crescent is the last hot
metal newspaper in the United States and
probably about anywhere
my family purchased the newspaper in
1917 it's just what we've always done
you know it's either stay in it or get
out and it's easier to stay in then get
out actually I've been working here
since I was 12 years old
I've been publisher for 37 years
the line of type that I used to set the
text for the newspaper we bought brand
new in 1921 I have about 440 subscribers
I print about 530 papers we put in
anything that people want to announce
you know anything that's going on a lot
of times it's an obituary
I've just maintained the traditional
printing method at the Crescent simply
because there hasn't been any reason to
change I'm not old enough for it to have
completely worn me out I've just been
able to just go on week to week the
future of the paper is that it'll be put
out next week I'm pretty sure probably a
week after that and it could be 20 years
it could be 2 years I I don't know I
think I'm as amazed about it as as most
people